listen to her
hey tick tock
[Music]
you know what's crazy because I um joke
a lot about
being single and
you know
I um
I laugh it off
but I'm 46 years old
and while I'm getting ready for surgery
and everything
it dawned on me
I'm sorry
it dawned on me
that I'm 46 years old
and I don't have a husband to take care
of me
I don't have a husband too
help me
get ready
thank you
I'm 46 years old and
I still need my mama
to take care of me post-op
I still need my sister which whether I
had a husband or not they would they
would be there
it sucks
being single and 46.
sucks
that's it
it just sucks
and I'm [ __ ] tired
and I make jokes about
the [ __ ] buffoons that I have been
encountering
in in dating
but in reality this is this is my
reality
this is my reality
this is my reality and this
those stories are the [ __ ] that's
available because all the good men have
gotten married
in their 20s and 30s because they're
good men
I'm not blaming it all on men because
women are [ __ ] [ __ ] they [ __ ]
batshit crazy too so
but I'm this is my reality not anybody
else's
that's all
wow
see
you notice the hoop earrings you know
you know
but even without the hoop earrings that
re that realization is coming for so
many women within the next 10 to 15
years
yeah yeah no I that's really sad
um and that's the thing do you think
it's selfish to not get married because
then your family has to take care of you
and then you're your family's
responsibility okay so we can talk about
America who's talking about marriage
right or long-term long-term
relationship yeah because
the bottom line is who's gonna look
after you
like he's looking after you like are you
just gonna be single and it's like your
mom and your dad's probably your mom
your dad like maybe if you got children
they get a look and they're older than
you like that shouldn't be their job you
know their job but she probably lived a
hot girl summer for what 10 years she
said 46. she's 46 now I was like yeah
she looked good for 40 seconds actually
it's good for 46 but she probably and
that's probably what the problem is yeah
and then I was she thought oh my God I
look young and I'm gonna let my hot girl
summer yeah like that's 25 years of of
[ __ ] yeah literally and that's the
thing that that is what is coming I
wonder if she had next husband
say again I wonder if she had an
ex-husband
I mean look when I see and the thing is
that video
is not in isolation there are so many
videos there's so many videos of women
hitting the wall
right as Kevin Samuel says that may you
rest in power
um and realizing oh my God like what I
was doing
is not working and now I am single at
this age and it's not working and it's
like that is that like I said with
depression
anger bitterness is coming like what did
they say what did Kevin Samuel say
winter is coming
winter is coming for you ladies okay
it's coming for you but the thing is
because you're so stubborn and because
you don't want to listen and because
everyone's a misogynist and everybody
hates women you are not going to take it
on until the last until the last minute
I'm just a big believer like I feel like
you should always try and a lot of times
like modern women have given up before
they've even tried what do you mean like
they don't listen like they've never
taken a second to listen to what men
want and they'll complain about their
outcomes but you like you didn't even
try
and like that's half of what like men
want to see from women they just want to
see women that like try they're so used
to like not having girls that don't try
at all in the relationship where they're
doing everything women don't listen Poe
you know they listen to their
girlfriends they're in their Echo
Chambers
yeah oh my God he's men of this man of
that yeah yeah girl they all they do is
confirmation by it and they'll always
sabotage like unless the guy is an
absolute simp they're gonna sabotage
like women's relationships that they do
have when they are happy unless they're
like they'll only not do it if the guy's
an absolute simp who lets her do
whatever she wants so let's do a let's
do a hypothetical scenario so you find a
guy you get married right and
you speak the way you speak within this
space okay right
those those modern day women those
Super Saiyan feminists right they're
gonna try and destroy your relationship
just to make themselves you said need to
be right yeah just to make themselves be
right oh well she couldn't even hold a
relationship down because now they're on
why it's power not in a relationship
what's wrong with her why is she not
married so they're trying to destroy
yourself it's always the personal
attacks but like is what I'm saying true
or is it not true and that's and that's
like that's the that's all you need to
know and you could they could go after
anything yeah everything no I actually I
was thinking I like I feel like I'd
rather date a guy that has no idea like
what my YouTube channel is right it's
like because if they see you in a happy
relationship do you think they're not
going to try and come for that oh no
they will Oh They'll Come for that I
mean I've been in like a public
relationship before and I kind of I've
seen the problems that come with it
Devin it's there's a lot of problems
that come with they are vindictive and
evil man like I even remember after
doing the um the show that we've done on
the possible Bros right a few weeks ago
some of the comments that I got
from women I'm just like listen if you
because women are like we don't care
about guys going abroad
and on the other hand they're making
whole videos about guys I'm just saying
we should learn from them like that's
what I say like why on Earth if
someone's winning okay like if you see a
a particular demographic winning yeah
winning study them let's yeah let's
let's take notes what recipes you all
know that are making these men yeah
exactly but the thing is it's surprises
especially if they're average looking
I'm like but it's the price of an eagle
Pearl right of the modern day one the
pride and the ego makes them think that
they are the ones that know everything
everyone outside of them doesn't know
ish they don't know [ __ ] right so it's
like what do those Filipino women know
what do those tie with me something
they're the most swiped real like Asian
chicks are the most swiped right on
dating at something no they don't know
nothing because I know and that's and
that is the ego of the one and that's
what they say Pride becomes pride comes
before the fall
that's what's gonna happen to Monday
women
Pride's gonna come before the fool as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis
Bay form if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible